[Music]
this week we've got protect then attack
South perking slippers and baby eyebrow
waxing oh my god sound crazy and cool I
wonder if it's like baby eyebrows are
getting waxed or baby's eyebrows they're
gonna be crying or baby waxing eyebrows
a little baby yeah baby sighs I before
they put the [ __ ] like a peach fuzz
eyebrow yeah it's a broad first story
the protectant attack story so there was
this man in New Zealand who rescued a
seagull and after he rescued the
seagulls started attacking them
something show you the seagull attack
the man makes sense for real well why
would the seagull be like thank you for
helping me I'm gonna like its ungrateful
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] ungrateful [ __ ] you
made them feel that way dumb ass animals
aren't like I never saving a seagull
that rugged that's why they're made for
burgers especially bird brains that's
why they're made for burgers how cute
seagulls are mean they try steal your
sandwich Johnson that he looks like that
cuz he looks like a criminal but he has
such a soft I'm far away from Tiffany
the screen is small and it's added angle
I know why you thought he was a criminal
though I know I got you dog no it's
because you thought he was black that's
why you racist [ __ ] yeah you got caught
racial profiling ho how can I be racist
I have a half asian baby I don't know
but you don't like black people let's
continue don't say that illness bleep I
love all people I don't like any people
I think I like people that are mean yeah
I don't care
no yeah as soon as he found the seagull
he turned on his Facebook live so I show
his bro
Facebook live I love it yeah so huge you
would think you hold them differently
after that like the second time like
after ones it's like okay he probably
didn't want to look mean at all he was
like saying I mean I
I don't know you're saying just bleeped
up he was like.he little thing I don't
know if it was funny but nothing he's
also like oh excuse the language and
then like two seconds later yeah but so
he says that he he went back to the area
where he lives and by the time he got
home everything was closed down like all
the vet and the SPCA SPC it yeah and so
he said that she could just put him in a
box in the blanket over nine he and some
wet bread and then when he went to go
check on the seagull in the morning it
was stiff as a rock Oh passed away so
she you want to save him Dave always
freaking get that angry on his way out
what angry bird dude you can't stress
out Birds too much or they can die I got
a pelican before I went fishing at
Marina del Rey and then you know like
when you use like a like an anchovy like
this one right you hook it like you just
put the whole thing on and when you cast
it Oh
a pelican came and it just grabbed it
and I was like reeling in a pelican yes
and then the pelican was like on the on
the dock and it was just I had a line
and I was like [ __ ] and at the time I
was like 10 or something and they were
making me do it like I gotta put my and
then I'm like [ __ ] I can't get it but
get my hand you're its mouth is gonna
freak invite me so I just cut the line
so the pelican just has a hook in its
mouth right now oh you just knocked it
out that guy's huge his mouth was like
well I was 10 so like it looks like it's
big one of the ugliest birds that has
ever got I got [ __ ] testicle neck and
[ __ ] like a scrotum that good it's
efficient to its job
you know pelicans eat other birds too
why no birds eat another Brit like I saw
a seagull eating another seagull one
time yeah yeah yeah so a seagull had
died and was on the beach and like the
other seagulls were like eating its
heart like eating and they just like
kept her taking turns like pecking at it
it was like damn where's our [ __ ]
crazy that I've ever seen an eagle hunt
a mountain goat No
like the Eagle will just come and fly
down with the crazy talents
grant sink it into the back of a go fly
and swing them off a cliff and then boom
and then that you go comes after that
boats dead it's a go
birds are carrion gold they probably got
like 5 foot wingspans you've got these
huge talons that just like my brother
has a deathly fear of birds it's the
funniest thing I've ever seen in my life
birds like like hummingbirds might be
like we're just chilling right I forgot
well we were at a Costco and a pigeon
came up I just found there's tons of
pigeons at Costco it's just like freaked
out something must happen to him as a
kid New York maybe he was a mouse in a
past life perhaps I feel like I'm
turning more and more Chinese as a day
goes by because all the animals are
starting to make me salivate because
you're massaging yourself with the
mallet next story Toyota oh no sorry
nice I like to I like the aura Nissan so
Nissan Skyline I'd like the skyline but
the rest of the brand sucks
I like Honda the only got like one or
two cars I'd like any brains I used to
be dog dude remember to 300 Z and in the
300 wait is it the SX no the 240sx and
in the 300 they had so many cool cars
but you know what happened to Nissan my
I got ruined
what happened bunch of our minions
started driving and that's what happened
oh the Altima the Optima and that 300 Z
it's the Mexicans love awesomest you
it's them you weren't sure not to get
ultimate let's get Altima Coupe never
yeah you told me
nor was it yes it was our corridor the
Altima Coupe no a Volvo
I never said nissan altima with the big
rims the Brill car the Nissan they are
using their profile at Park System on
these slippers and like these items in a
hotel in Japan so I'm going to show you
guys oh yeah that's awesome
they Park them so we thought Markey
before needs that [ __ ] I'm always over
his [ __ ] supers that looks like two
samurais about the freaking dual each
other or curvaceous or not that is Joe
oh man they're like Healy's Oh
everything puts itself away everything's
so [ __ ] awesome in Japan that is real
they use the same technology Japanese
are just like [ __ ] you this is how soap
we are and someone's that someone's job
to do that you know what's pretty cool
that still I like that I'm with it no
one's job was working on a self-parking
slipper like that's what he did for a
year this Nissan made a new leaf you
know they're ugly-ass electric car you
want actually looks decent so good good
on them the car person that I'm gonna
listen to about opinions vagina boy
first of all I have no idea what pieces
have to do a vagina are you looking for
an Elantra or something like that
it was a Prius and the reason why
because it saves the earth shut the [ __ ]
you look at you you [ __ ] earth killer
you don't like black people oh yes baby
wreckages of Amazon do you receive on a
daily you see the [ __ ] earth I do
because I take those cardboard boxes and
I build homes for homeless people
did you even think about that yeah you
didn't did you all right yeah I also
create cuts out in the give them water
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you win let's continue you got skills
yeah when are we gonna see her your
projects yeah
oh you'll see it all over us get ro I'm
with them all the time
what street is get wrong huh Skid Row is
on Skid Row Street Julian and San Pedro
thank you sir
it's 4x15 or something like that next to
Little Tokyo I don't need to know the
exact streets because I live there isn't
a Prius a hybrid though it's not a full
electric it's not but it saves the earth
by a lot I have a Honda Civic Hybrid
come at me bro exactly you saved the
earth - thank you very much yeah [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah you stupid a BMW was it you don't
want to do Tesla yeah yeah see I'm just
saving the earth wait you say have a
Prius Ana Tesla no I have a Honda
Element car but now he has a cool car
you wanna save the earth drive a bus
Leigh I'm gonna get that Nissan Leaf are
you really why do you collect these cars
like I like to get cars that nobody
wants I don't know what but a Nissan
Leaf actually has a decent like range so
the issue that a lot of these electric
cars have they know why you need this
ring like most car collectors colored
cool cars what's wrong with these hey
until you drive an electric car you will
not know what I'm talking about
they're fantastic no one wants to see a
car collection energy to build all these
cars I don't know what the [ __ ] it does
I'm just saying I haven't gone to a gas
station in a minute
all that's true so you'll get robbed you
plug it into the wall at home is that
how they do it ok that's interesting
yeah well speaking of the leaf there's
talking about this pro pilot park system
that they're using on these slippers it
was first introduced in the leaf so yeah
Oh leaf was the first car that southport
no Tesla is it - well for a new the
first Nissan the first thing I can't
believe they're still alive I don't know
I get kind of a confidence level from
parking my own car yeah I'm so good at
this and I feel like a genius like they
take about a lifetime really I do
yeah it's made it so much better like I
can park in the tightest spots I like
where there's like this much space in
between and I feel so ball after I'm
like I'm ready for this meeting it's
pretty cool though when your car can
self parallel park it's like you don't
have to think of [ __ ] you know if you
get out first let it park itself or do
you
anyway for the parka if you come next to
a cop I could it'll actually reverse
Park into an actual parking space -
that's dope but do you feel like it's
gonna be like digital clocks where you
know like a lot of kids don't know how
to read a clock anymore
oh for sure because like when I go back
to the Honda Element it takes me a good
five minutes to figure out how this car
works okay because I'll sit in the car
and I'm like you're waiting for a
turn-on
no kids don't know how to read time they
can't read at all because I'd like
spellcheck like follow the autos yeah
all the clocks in schools are digital so
like they never learn how to read a
clock so just to put it in perspective
like how much the the [ __ ] tests are
handicapped me I went to go get a get a
haircut so by the time I came out I when
I came out to the car my car was on and
I was like yo what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this car how's it on by itself what
actually happened was I left the key in
the ignition and the car odd someone's
running the whole time the whole time
and I want to get a haircut okay you're
still alive amazing so it usually
happens with the Tesla I walk out it
locks by itself the keys are on my
pocket always so I'm so used to that
[ __ ] yeah I feel like Google cars are
gonna replace all the cars anyway I want
that I don't ever want to drive I don't
want to drive I don't you [ __ ] however
the car is you don't get that like a
good job anyway
yeah you're a sore boy ride a horse
everywhere that if I ask you if I see
your ass in a [ __ ] car I'm shooting
that [ __ ] down you ride a [ __ ] horse
and Heather should tear up your [ __ ]
everyday I would love it I want a jet
pack yeah actually it feels kind of nice
have you been on a horse 40 minutes
I mean I'm not a horse it's like being
on a washing machine and you know I
don't it is like somebody it's giving
you an uppercut machine I have it's not
the same as a horse gotta be honest so
these two Washington State moms are
saying that the daycare that their kids
go to waxed orchids I reckon so
yes so here's the little girl the first
one she's about two years old and like
she has you know baby hairs I can see
why they wax Ribe I cannot see that she
picked up her kids oh I would be [ __ ]
sorry I'll be like thank you my baby got
caterpillars there's a little boy the
mom was just pointing out I guess like
this is before she's like I'm gonna
cover my face but not the kids well he
looks good here yes it does look good
though
no I'll be good that song don't touch my
child have you guys have gotten your
eyebrows waxed no funny now they'll be
used to it by the time that they want if
I came to pick up my kid and he looks
like a superstar after I mean who's to
get ahead that's like dropping your dog
off at the like dog sitter and then it
comes back groomed yeah thank you what's
the what's the problem here is a child
like you wouldn't mind if someone
altered its being hot wax that that
could be painful but it might get have
some caterpillar ass look at high brows
and it came out pristine as [ __ ] I'd be
like thank you thank you like just I
mean pretty nice why guess you're really
against caterpillar eyebrows I just for
me I wouldn't care non-consent part of
it that part they're like hey yo uh your
kid looks like Eddy monster I thought
that was like a part of the package
though or something
there's before your time but he does
look like any monster I'm too young and
pretty to know yeah so the moms are
fuming they're like oh they're two
different moments two different ones who
are friends oh so they're like they I
think they did this to Mike here - yeah
someone there has like an obsession with
cleaning up eyebrows yeah she's like she
wants it she's going a cosmopolitan mix
drinks sounds like they're saying that
they did an internal fact-finding
because the Boys and Girls Club are the
ones that oversee this particular Baker
but they're saying that they found the
accusations unsubstantiated yeah because
they look amazing yeah they're just
saying cause they know what that means
is they looked into the law and how much
they could get sued for and they were
like nope we don't want this you can't
find any evidence or it could have been
some older kids that did it - and I had
nothing to do at the faculty these are
the boys and yeah boys and girls club
right that's all ages yeah but but this
particular care like a daycare a little
kid they don't usually mix oh I'm just
saying the eyebrows are great that's all
I'm saying I know but they're little
babies don't you know their eyebrows why
would you want to make who are you
making them attractive for I'm not
making them attractive for anything I'm
just saying that those things need to be
tamed and they put many teams of the
team for whom and what else it prevents
them from getting beat up what if you
have into getting beat up every day and
now boom you don't get beat up they came
into class another little kid said hey
look at your eyebrows [ __ ] ugly no
build character okay yeah and then they
were like you are not allowed to call
him ugly anymore come here and then they
fixed the eyebrows and the kid came out
and there was glitter and a [ __ ]
disco ball came down and then
who's that body in first grade I had a
friend at first grade we called her
Harry sue name wasn't sue by the way but
then she had a mustache and I felt bad
because I was like how come someone
doesn't do anything about your mustache
you were hauled first grade oh damn yeah
wait how old are these kids can they
talk two and three oh so they can't say
like whether it is not small they don't
know any men plus like the moms are
saying too like if they did this to my
kid like what else did they do that
we'll check the butthole two zillion wax
when they confronted that thing did they
say anything the people um they were
just like oh we don't know what you're
talking about like they just tried
pushing it off like we're not
responsible for this it's because they
don't wanna get sued cuz hot wax see
because it's it's hot wire yeah that's
how they do you know what really hurts
is the the tweezers oh I should make my
Terra how do they know it was wax though
you could see them clean like yeah when
when it's like plucking you still have
like many tiny little baby hairs but
then when it's waxing all of the hair
yeah you know what doesn't hurt the
indian threading that hurts well really
cuz I got it bad I didn't hurt you
maybe I'm just wrong you get your
eyebrows waxed and then you tweeze you
can't feel it anymore because it's like
numb there so what if they use that one
product you know back in the day the
mayor he liked that one you know we
definitely really [ __ ] up that church
and a retreat we replace this guy's
shampoo with their oh how godly did it
is hair fall we mixed it a little bit so
a good chunk of it fell out and I think
if I can remember correctly he was
supposed to shave his head cuz he lost a
bet and he wouldn't do it oh then that's
fair so if he's not being honorable you
should do it okay so okay a guy made fun
of me an ex-boyfriend like broke up with
me and told me like one of the things
that I had a mustache so like I neared
my lip and I was like really
self-conscious about it and I narrowed
it but you're not supposed to rub it at
all like when you take it off you can't
like rub it off like you have to like
lie
we like wipe it like when one stroke so
I like thought I was doing that boat
kind of rubbing it and it made like a
scabby mustache instead of hairs like
way worse and it's like it was like
[ __ ] scabby like and then every day
when you like wash your face it like
it's like green again it was the
grossest [ __ ] and it was all cuz he like
made me feel bad for having a mustache
but now I pluck it whiskas yeah well you
know good for him so if that kid rubbed
it at all yeah I mean it was there and
then we were laughing and he kind of
figured with a little tough came out and
then you know y'all good you ladies
should do a experiment of just letting
everything grow hair arms people are
doing that now that's like a whole
woman's movement yeah well not even for
like for like feminism or anything just
for experiments just to see what it
looks like why are you always
controlling our life it's a suggestion
for like something fun is not that fun
sometimes it naturally grew it grows out
because like I got too busy during the
week or whatever and it's like I just
feel dirty
like I like feeling swell I experiment
with my body all the time alright
[Music]
[Music]